[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight this week the Trump
administration revealed its proposal to
overhaul America's immigration system
the proposal would not by itself build
the often promised wall on our southern
border nor would it cut current levels
of immigration despite the fact that
most Americans would like to see that
happen the one big thing the
administration's proposal would do is
give priority to immigrants who might
actually help America skilled workers
with English proficiency it's hard to
see an argument against a system like
that there isn't really an argument
against that system for years Democrats
have argued that immigrants make vital
additions to our economy they're smarter
than we are they're harder working they
do better in school they found more
companies well the president has decided
to take Democrats at their word he says
he wants all of those good things that
immigrants bring watch we want
immigrants coming in we cherish the open
door that we want to create for our
country but a big proportion of those
immigrants must come in through merit
and skill well much the world would move
here if they could hundreds and hundreds
of millions of people so why wouldn't we
pick the absolute best immigrants with
skills and English would fit in better
here their kids would do better in
school they'd be more likely to
contribute to social programs instead of
draining them so are Democrats rejoicing
in this change of course not they're
outraged House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
spoke for the party when she declared
that really merit is a bad word because
everybody has merit I want to just say
something about the word that they use
merit it is really a condescending word
they're saying family is without merit
are they saying most of the people have
ever come to the United States in the
history of our country or without merit
because they don't have an engineering
degree certainly we want to attract the
best in our country to our country and
that includes many people for many parts
of society what a shame we can't staff
the Democratic caucus in the Congress
using the same criteria the speaker
would like to to fill our country we
want to attract the best for many parts
of the world she says but but of course
by that [ __ ] doesn't mean what she says
she means just the opposite
because what exactly is best about
immigrants who have criminal records or
middle school education or no ability to
hold a job the answer is there's nothing
best about that immigrants like that
might be nice people but they're much
more likely to burden the United States
than to benefit at least economically
Harvard doesn't admit students who can't
speak English it says so right on their
website so why should our country the
left doesn't want to answer questions
like that or even have the conversation
shut up racist and said that it's
declared that the current system is
great no evidence necessary watch this
former Obama official make her facts
free case on MSNBC yesterday what's less
obvious is that medium and even the
least skilled immigrants also contribute
to the US economy they come in and they
do different things for natives and they
allow everyone to specialize more and
what they're doing best is that
contribution of the unskilled immigrants
that I think people overlook when they
really push the so-called merit-based or
the has it's called in other countries
the point system uh-huh so what
Professor hunt and so many on the Left
including the Speaker of the House are
arguing for is a feudal system where
foreign-born worker bees toil to support
a smug and pampered managerial class of
which they of course are part there's no
other explanation for our current
policies we don't need more low-skilled
workers in the united states we have
plenty of low-skilled workers their
unemployment rate is higher than the
national average their wage growth has
been abysmal for decades generations so
how do those workers benefit from having
more competition of course they don't
how does the country benefit by having
more low-skilled workers when
technological changes may soon render
millions of them permanently jobless the
answer of course is that we won't
benefit but for the left whether the
country benefits is not the point
congresswoman Ilhan Omar herself a
symbol of America's failed immigration
system if there ever was one someone who
hates this country coming here at public
expense spent yesterday demanding the AB
coalition of ice the decriminalization
of illegal immigration itself and an end
to all deportation programs she demands
open borders the unlimited arrival of
anyone who wants to come to America
whether they have anything to contribute
or not and by the way you get to pay for
it and if you don't want to you're a
bigot
well you know this is really about of
course it's not about civil rights
that's a joke it's about money and power
their money their power the left has
aligned with business interests that
profit from cheap obedient workers
low-skilled immigrants have a harder
time assimilating into the American
mainstream they stay poorer they learn
English more slowly they're more likely
to remain an ethnic underclass all of
which makes them much more likely to
vote Democratic long term that's the
point obviously skilled immigrants might
assimilate and become less reliable
democratic voters they might even
compete with the children of our ruling
class that's not allowed it's safer to
import serfs and that's exactly what
they're doing don't let them tell you
it's about civil rights it's not it's
about their convenience and their power